right well um
thank you everyone for joining today
what i will do in my part of the
presentation is briefly give you the
background of
metagenomics
and kind of
following
some of the resources that you will also
find in the introductory materials on
the learning portal
for anyone who would like to kind of get
familiar with these concepts before we
start the program
so you know i want to kind of start from
the very beginning and talk a little bit
about um you know why
the microbiome
and and how exactly can we study the
microbiome so since the discovery of the
microscope
we've been learning about microorganisms
that surround us and even live inside us
and uh with the increasing resolution so
here we have a chart of the
different types of uh
small
things that you can see in the
microscope
you can see that the optical microscopy
resolution allows us to see kind of all
the way to uh bacteria and because of
that um
this kind of interest
in the way that this micro
the micro organisms live together
has evolved as the resolution allowed us
to see small and smaller things so what
you can see here on the bottom
is a
figure this is an image from a
microscope a
super high resolution microscope where
you can see e coli
and some phages so these are viruses
that
are sitting on the e coli bacteria so
what has been uh has become clear with
the increasing resolution is that not
only
that there are trillions of
microorganisms around us they also live
in communities and they interact with
each other not just with their hosts or
their environment
so um
because of that
early on there has been an
acknowledgement of the role that the
microbes play in human health and
well-being and early on you can see here
in the mid 1600s there was the first
observation of microscopic organism and
by the 1800s there has been an
association made between disease and
microorganisms but today
in the last couple of decades there has
been a tremendous increase in research
concerning the role of the microbiome in
a variety of different conditions that
affect the environment but also affect
us as people including different aspects
of human health and development
of the healthy microbiome on the skin
in the gut and in other organs
and what we will talk about today are
several examples
just to kind of understand uh what are
some of the considerations you know how
is the microbiome studied what are some
technologies that have been used do that
how these technologies are evolving and
what we will cover in the program to be
able to handle such data uh practically
and and kind of understand the insights
that we can gain from uh such data
so uh one important factor about the
microbiome is the stability so
essentially uh these communities of
bacteria um
specifically we'll talk more about the
bacteria rather than just the whole
microbiome
we can kind of all relate to the
stability of these communities when we
think about
such
microbiome communities like our skin
so for example microbiome on the skin
will create a biofilm
and this biofilm can actually
communicate with each other by producing
detecting and responding to small
diffusible signal molecules in a process
called quorum sensing which confirms
confirms benefit for hosts colonization
biofuel information defense against
competitors and adaptation to changes in
the environment
and quorum sensing activities
are also involved in the violence and
pathogenic potential of bacteria and so
they're an important factor in
understanding and controlling bacteria
and bacterial infections as they enable
microorganisms in biofilms to become
more tolerant of host defenses and
antimicrobial agents and inside each
community there is going to be a balance
of bacteria fungi and viruses that
control species abundance and skin so if
you touch your own skin
uh you will feel that there is more than
just
you know one type of feeling on your
skin right some
parts of your skin might be dry some of
them might be oily some of them might
feel smooth or or might have bumps on
them so all of this means that there's
this whole microbiome interacting with
the host and
one question that we might have is well
what factors are actually determining
some of the
qualities of this microbiome how are
these distinct communities different
from each other
because we know that all of our skins
are probably very different from each
other but also how
do the things that we can control affect
these communities and so to answer some
of these questions
there has been a tremendous interest in
understanding
characterization
and
you know investigation of the factors
that really control the microbial
communities in many different organs so
you can see here on the screen
some of those
defined microbiomes like the microbiome
of the skin the respiratory system the
gut the intestines the stomach uh the
urogenital tract uh so all of these um
since uh
2010 i believe there have been hundreds
of thousands of papers um related to the
microbiome and major projects that have
been developed so some of the major
projects that you can see right here in
2010 we have the human microbiome
project that we will talk a lot about
in this program but also throughout the
years there have been distinct projects
focused on the gut skin lung and even
brain microbiomes so many of these
projects like the human microbiome
project seem
uh
seek to
characterize the healthy microbiome
because there's a lot of variation as we
already discussed and we'll talk about
in in a few slides uh related to the age
to the location uh to the diet and
lifestyle as well as the environment of
the healthy microbiome but then also an
additional set of projects have been
designed to address some of the
questions around disease so you can see
here cancer prevention study
for microbiome in cancer
you can see the alzheimer's gut
microbiome project the nurses health
study and others and so
really we can see here a variety of
disciplines that will be affected by the
microbiome from healthy nutrition and
lifestyle all the way to a variety of
precision medicine applications and even
you can see here on the bottom
space travel right so it appears to also
play a role
in space
travel and the health of
astronauts and so many different areas
of application for metagenomics and for
microbiome
so um because of all of these projects
we know today that the human microbial
communities contribute to
many critical and essential metabolic
physiological and immunological
functions and they include
differentiation and maturation of the
host mucosa and its immune system food
digestion and nutrition energy
generation metabolic regulation and
control of fat storage
processing and detoxification of
environmental chemicals maintenance of
skin and mucosal barrier of function
development and regulation of the immune
system prevention of invasion and growth
of disease promoting microorganisms and
several others and so to study
these conditions and this variability
there are several different types of
omics technologies to study the
microbiome and these could be
distinguished into
a sequencing based or mass spectrometry
based so for sequencing we can look at
the dna based approaches so essentially
we can sequence
specific genes or try to assemble whole
genomes of
bacteria or whatever species of these
microorganisms
we can also look at rna based so we can
try to infer function what are some of
the genes that are being expressed
and and what do they mean what is their
function there are also ways to study
the microbiome using mass spectrometry
where we can look at proteins and
metabolites that they produce
but today in in this session we'll talk
a little bit more in detail about
metagenomic sequencing
and so metagenomic sequencing
metagenomics in general could be
characterized as both a field and a
specific technique
to study the microbiome
but it is different from many other
types of omics so essentially many types
of omics
are focused on characterizing a single
system a single
individual for example when we speak
about the genomic studies we're trying
to understand the genome of an
individual
metagenomics
in that sense is different because it
looks at a community so specifically
when we speak about a community we think
of the microbiome as almost like an
organ that has a specific function
and
one of the ways that we want to
understand the function of this organ is
by capturing the diversity of
microorganism within that microbiome or
microbiota the community that it forms
and when we do that it is different from
a lab-based technique where essentially
a single
microorganism is isolated and is grown
in a different environment than where it
actually
typically lives and so because only one
to two percent of bacteria can be
cultured in the lab lab
metagenomics allows us to study
how these microorganisms coexist
together with others and respond
together to different environmental
changes or produce some functional
effects
so the um difference between these two
we can see here uh for
uh for example when we want to study the
gut microbiome uh one of the ways that
we can use sequencing to understand this
microbial community is by trying to
annotate the different taxonomic
variation
found within the gut
and sometimes we can also combine that
with an understanding of a particular
individual uh of a representative of
that community to try to understand what
is that specific individual bacteria for
example how is it different from others
right so we'll talk a little bit about
how these techniques could be applied to
different types of conditions in just a
moment but let's try to see how this
type of information could be generated
and what are some of the techniques to
then study the data that is being
generated from sequencing
so uh two uh kind of approaches that i
want to
discuss here the first one is sequence
based when we are able to sequence
all of the dna or the rna that is
present in a sample like next generation
sequencing
so this could be shotgun metagenomics
16s amplicon metagenomics or meta
transcriptomics
and then sometimes we also have these
approaches with qpcr when we know
that we're looking for specific types of
bacteria and we could design primers to
actually
find whether there is an abundance of a
particular type of a
bacteria or combinations of bacteria so
if you think about
the
next few slides you'll see how both of
these could probably be applied to
answer similar questions
but we'll more speak about next
generation sequencing because of the
richness of information that it can
provide us with and
how we can apply qbcr for example to
validate the findings that we will see
in next generation sequencing
so really shotgun metagenomics or meta
transcriptomics differs from 16s
amplicon metagenomics in the way that
we're able to capture the specific
view of the composition of the microbial
community using 16s amplicon
metagenomics or essentially thinking
about the 16s ribosomal rna as a marker
gene that helps us understand taxonomy
and then shotgun metagenomics or
metatranscriptomics is the analysis of
all of the genes within an ecosystem so
the difference is are we sequencing all
of the genes or all of the gene node or
are we looking at conserved marker genes
or gene regions
and some of the challenges that are
associated with both of these approaches
so first of all in
trying to
sequence all of the data that is present
in the dna that we extract from this
microbial community obviously assembly
is going to be one of the major
challenges how do you take these short
reads and try to piece them together to
extend them into an assembled genome or
at least a part of the genome that then
we can search for specific genes and try
to annotate them so even with 16s
amplicon sequencing we have this
challenge of annotation as well because
essentially not all of the bacterial
genomes are known but because we have
databases that are constantly being
updated
because of these major studies it is
possible to define the taxonomy or the
diversity and the presence or absence of
specific types of bacteria in a given
sample
so let's uh kind of talk about 16s
metagenomic sequencing and
try to understand the specific
applications of 16s metagenomic
sequencing which i think are
very exciting in the context of
human health and well-being different
types of disease applications and even
behavior as we will see
so 16s amplicon sequencing is a
technique that is widely used
one of the most
kind of widely used techniques
and this sequencing focuses focuses on
the 16s ribosomal rna gene so first that
gene is amplified with pcr amplification
and that gene contains hyper variable
regions that allow us to study taxonomy
of a particular community so one of the
challenges with the actual sequencing is
first to organize the sequences that we
get into what we call operational
taxonomic units and these are units that
resemble each other with some specific
markers
and then we can use those to annotate
and try to understand what do they match
in a database
and so there are several different
databases like the silva
green genes
there's ncbi
repository of all of the bacterial
genomes
and as well as rdp so what do these
databases essentially provide us with
so these databases can help us
understand taxonomy or if we think about
the hierarchy of biological
classification how we can study
the
more or less detailed view of the
different types of organisms so the
taxonomy is just a way to organize the
different types of organisms into some
kind of a structure so we can see what
is more related or less related so
starting from the bottom here kingdom
phylum class order family genus and all
the way to species now as you will see
not all of these are going to be
available for all of the individual
microbial organisms that we will have
and so what
what we can try to assess
are the differences at maybe
specific levels like for example class
phylum or order or sometimes dig deeper
into the species level of classification
so to really understand how diverse the
microbiome is
and how
many organisms organisms we're dealing
with let's actually look at the silva
database and we'll see there how
how many different organisms organisms
you are going to be finding there so i'm
going to paste the link
in the chat box and i will actually
address your questions here in a few
minutes
so um please go with me to this link
okay so
this is
the database
the silva database
here you will find
the different levels
so right here you can see those levels
domain phylum family major clade class
genus kingdom and order and so you can
see here
bacteria right that's the kingdom and
then it goes all the way down to family
right here
so what you can do here is you can
search by sequences
by session number or by full name and
here you will
be able to find by taxon name or you can
also
browse here specific types of bacteria
so
as we go through i will give a couple of
examples
of bacteria that you will be able to
find here and
search for it right here in the taxon
name and then you'll be able to find it
okay
beyond the bacteria right what we need
to remember is that a microbiome
contains also viruses
as well as
other microorganisms so
because we have this interaction between
bacteria the community that it forms and
other microorganisms right we won't talk
about it as much today but you have to
remember that
the same types of databases exist for
other microorganisms that you might
expect to find in the
microbiome
so again viruses for example um as well
as you can see here the the viral right
so in the same way that we can call the
microbiome all of the microorganisms we
can also look at specific
types of
microorganisms so for example for
viruses as well called the virule so
let's think about how these different
projects allow us now to study the
microbiome to understand first of all
healthy microbiome and healthy variation
right so we'll look at this left side of
the screen the human microbiome project
you can see some examples here american
gut project british gut project
etc
okay let me take a look at
some of the questions
okay so um are there any specific
databases related to cancer microbiome
and cancer so there are some studies
that have shown
a specific variation in the microbiome
that can lead to more successful
treatments for example with
immunotherapy
right we'll talk about this in a little
bit but um essentially
one thing that we need to understand is
that we need to have a healthy baseline
right when you think of any pathology
any condition you're comparing it to
someone and we'll see first of all the
variability in the healthy microbiome
and after we take a look at the at the
healthy microbiome we'll also discuss
how this applies to medical applications
and to our understanding
i got a question why does every time
uh ilya i'm so sorry to intro but we
can't hear you i think you're on me
sorry about that yeah
thank you so
um uh so yeah so what i was saying is
that there is this uh in utero
colonization hypothesis this hypothesis
is um that uh there is a
uh um a microbiome that is passed to the
baby in the
uterus
um
and uh
so uh somebody i think there's somebody
here that is um not supposed to be here
um okay so um
this hypothesis claims that um
there is a way uh to
um
pass the microbiome to the baby from the
mother and the womb uh there isn't maybe
enough um
evidence that that is uh conclusive
um and um as a result we won't focus on
that hypothesis but let's talk about
some of the additional factors that do
play a role in the development of the
microbiome that have been studied
extensively in infants
infants that are between zero and three
years
so um
would you be able to just remove the
people um
yes i'm doing that all right so some of
those include gestational age so how
long a baby stays in the womb
uh the birth mode for example caesarean
or natural
sanitation
antibiotic exposure is a major one um
as well as host genetics
so several different studies have
focused on trying to understand these
factors in detail
and now we have some evidence of how the
composition changes and how
specific presence or absence of bacteria
could be linked to some of these factors
now what happens in the early ages is
that because this is an anaerobic
condition
specific types
of
bacteria start developing
and what you can do as i mentioned the
link
that i
just shared with you to the silva
database will allow you to
search for some of these bacteria so for
example we can take a look at
clostridia
and search for this name in that
database so
let's take a look at that
so you would go right here
and just type in clostridia
and press on search
okay so as you can see
um clostridia again you can go kind of
from uh the higher level of toxicotomy
all the way down to the more detailed
one uh so this is a fermicutes
right uh basili
um
ariza er rizzy pela trichaelis
uh right i'm not gonna try to pronounce
this but you can see the variation right
here
at this level of how many different ones
you're going to be able to find and so
you can zoom in
okay you can zoom in and you can see
that there's a lot of
variability
so again
there's going to be
a lot of
a lot of variability and that is
essentially what makes it so difficult
to study this kind of variation
at the lower levels right so the lower
the level the more detail we get but at
the same time we're going to be getting
uh
[Music]
we're going to be getting
um you know a lot of information
potentially from that so
here is an example
of a study
that uh was done on the effect of
probiotics
on the infant development uh
specifically infants
that are
pre-term infants pre-term birth so here
you can see composition of the gut
microbiome at the early phase of
development dominated by four phyla
actinobacteria bacteria deities
firmicutes and proteobacteria right so
we just saw that these are specific
types of bacteria right and here we can
see
that it is dominated by these specific
groups of bacteria
um the adult microbiome so again um this
develops over three uh first years
typically uh so there's less of a
diversity at the very very early
stage and then that diversity grows and
starts to become established during the
adolescence so from
that early uh childhood all the way to
the end of the adolescent period the
microbiome becomes established and the
primary factors that affect the
established microbiome are the use of
antibiotics so how frequently and how
intensively those antibiotics have been
used as well as the level of exercise
and of course diet
and so here you can see the adult
microbiome and this is well
characterized in the human microbiome
project
is really divided into these several
different categories by the major
factors that continue to affect the
microbiome over the course of the adult
stable condition and those are specific
enterotypes two or three enterotypes
that are well studied
body mass index exercise frequency
different types of lifestyles and then a
major component are cultural and dietary
habits
so here we can see
a major thing that you want to think
about as you kind of look at this
healthy microbiome is
uh diversity and balance
as well as this dysbiosis so how it
changes how it becomes
you know dominated by a particular type
of bacteria that is maybe able to
colonize and suppress other types of
bacteria reducing the diversity and as a
result the function also changes and so
we'll see how that
kind of looks like in the data itself
so first of all let's briefly talk about
these as anterotypes so different types
of publications have been
focused on understanding these antenna
types but basically
we can look at two or three different
enterotypes
so here's an example in specific types
of bacteria bacteriodes uh prevotella
and
ruminococcus for example you can see
that they change in terms of their
relative abundance
but basically
specifically those that are interested
in the diet
you know they've been able to categorize
these three different enterotypes into
those that consume carbohydrates like
fruits and vegetables
then what we call the western diet
so bacteriodes dominant types um and
those are the western diet because
they're associated with kind of you know
the typical western diet like meats
potatoes and you know things like that
and then there is an additional cluster
that is not as dominant but it's
primarily for those that are coming from
rural agricultural communities they
don't have a lot of variety in their
source of nutrition
and
those are typically
farming communities so
those are the kind of major emerging
trends right that have uh come out of
these studies
um they've shown that there's definitely
an association of microbial diversity uh
because of the
type of a
civilization so to stay or
community that the samples come from so
it's especially talking about the human
gut microbiome
it could be categorized as very high in
this remote hunter gatherer population
kind of reduced but still pretty high
microbial diversity in the traditional
farming or fishing populations and then
lower diversity
in this western european and
industrialized populations and so here
you can see
also how
some of these variations have been
associated with geography
so one major reason is because the same
trend of industrialization could be
tracked across geography
but also not surprisingly uh some of
those habits associated with the type of
food could be found within a specific
population that maintains a specific
aspect of lifestyle and
food consumption so a good
review right here
geography ethnicity or substance
specific variation in human microbiome
composition and diversity
you can see
sorry let me go back
and share the link
from this publication
i found it um interesting if anybody's
trying to understand more
um how this
healthy human microbiome
varies and and what kinds of factors
are there
okay now because of this variation so
again think of the microbiome as a
community once that community is stable
it assumes certain functions that are
linked to immune
responses to different infections uh
they form a film a lot of times that
film is protective uh and so because of
that they're able to
kind of help protect
us from a variety of different
infections also by
maintaining a certain
immune response readiness
for a variety of
intruders that come but
because we also spoke not just about the
bacterial communities but we also spoke
about the viral communities
these microbes
are obviously involved in a variety of
different diseases and so the
understanding of not only the bacterial
diversity that we just spoke about but
also the potential of these viruses to
be present and develop and
get into the organs are very important
and here are some examples
of viruses that cause human disease so
also something that we can look at
as we study the microbiota
epstein-barr virus
the herpes family viruses in general
human papilloma virus and hepatitis b
and c are major conditions that drive
about a quarter of cancers right so the
link between microorganisms and human
health and disease is very
direct and so we can see
one
perspective when we look at the
microbial diversity and community that
is in a uh
in this whole beyond uh relationship
with the host uh so it it continues to
co-exist in a beneficial
way with the host
and then we can see some of these
becoming dangerous and causing
disease
okay so now let's take a look at a
couple of practical examples
what we will actually do during this
training program so in the training
program we will let's speak about how
this has been studied and less focused
on literature review but will more focus
on the practical skills how to actually
take the data that you can find in some
of these repositories and start asking
questions and what are the methods that
you need to know how to use to be able
to extract meaningful signals from the
data so
the first example that we will use is
the american gut project so this
american gut project is essentially a
platform for citizen science microbiome
research and so a lot of the
ways that we can start looking at this
data is representative of
semi-healthy right so either completely
healthy or kind of uh you know almost
healthy maybe some sensitivities and
some pre-clinical conditions but mostly
healthy
so this was a project um that
started a few years ago and essentially
people were able to contribute their
samples answer a survey a very detailed
survey as we will see and as a result
you could compare your microbiome with
other microbiomes that have been a part
of this project and also
as a result researchers could start
finding associations between certain
types of conditions and some of them
like we discussed so one of the results
that you got as a user and this is one
of the exercises that we will do in this
program is to try and replicate this
kind of a report for an individual
person an individual sample and compare
it to some of the other samples that we
have in the database so here you can see
an example of such a report
for example what is in your american gut
sample you can see here how the
proportion of these different types of
bacteria
is in your sample compared to a variety
of other
insights from the project for example
average similar diet same gender similar
bmi similar age
and this is uh you know your sample
compared to some specific person
um your most abundant microbes your most
enriched microbes and then you can see
here some of these methods of comparison
to other samples or collections of
samples so for example we can see a
major difference between different body
sites obviously
we can also see different ages and
populations and also you can see within
one population the difference and this
is the american gut population so you
can essentially where are you in this
population
so i think this actually is an older
link that now has changed uh but you
will be able we will what we will do in
the program is we will actually take a
look at the data that is available
about all of these different factors so
here you can see one of the comparisons
that we will try to do
is use 16s
metagenomic sequencing
amplicon sequencing of these
hypervariable regions v3 and v4 and try
to understand whether we can find some
variation based on regular or rare
exercise right so we'll actually
download the metadata you will see that
the metadata is quite complex
it comes with many different variables a
lot of the variables don't have data
that we can use so in all of this messy
data we'll try to select the ones that
we can design a contrast for and then we
will select those
download the
abundance of those
otus map those all to use to the
reference database and try to use that
information to ask the question is there
a specific difference between people who
exercise never or rarely or
regularly and even often and so one of
the things that you will find is that
this gives you a very good sense of the
variability right when we see these
results these publications that find a
link between a certain
factor
in the microbiome we will actually get
to experience that firsthand and see how
that process is done
another exercise that we will do is a
study of the skin microbiome which is
an important factor in such conditions
like acne
and and one of the data sets that we
will take is a comparison between
perioral dermatitis
adult acne and healthy skin
so perioral dermatitis is just a rash
like the redness of the skin and then
acne of course is a much more
intense condition
and so one of the questions would be you
know is there a microbiome component to
that so obviously there might be other
factors but how does the micro the skin
microbiome actually affect those
conditions so here
you can see a review article so we'll go
through this article as the review and
then we will take some data and we will
be able to compare some of those samples
to try to understand where is that
variability and what defines each one of
these conditions and we'll also think
about strategies to collect data that
allow us to make conclusive
um
get conclusive insights from such steps
another interesting uh study that we
will take a look at is the uh more
indirect link between behavior
and uh the gut microbiome so uh the gut
brain axis
is a
whole topic of study for many different
research studies so what we will do is
we'll take one of these example studies
that talks about obese type gut
microbiota that induce neurobehavioral
changes in the absence of obesity right
so
one direct association that we know of
is the gut microbiome and obesity right
and we can say well obesity itself
causes specific changes in behavior
but in this study they try to
separate obesity from the microbiome and
see whether the composition of the
microbiome actually does have an effect
on behavior and so what they did is they
took mice
using antibiotics they reduced the
bacterial load and then some were
recipients of this high fat diet or
regular diet microbiome and then what
they did is they tried to assess at the
end of this experiment whether there was
an association uh first of all if that
micro microbial community got
established and if it did establish did
it lead to some uh observable behavioral
change uh changes and so they actually
did some behavioral tests to see level
of anxiety
and things like that in the behavior so
after reading this paper and
understanding the data what we will do
is we will apply
a technique called
a pipeline called data2
that allows us to denoise the reeds
so that we have clear and clean
operational taxonomic units map those
onto uh the taxonomy available in the
silva database and from there develop a
certain sense of how to
process
and visualize such data
first of all using the t-biome for
platform just to kind of see the logic
of the analysis and the input the output
from each pipeline and then turning to r
to investigate further how we can modify
and uh visualize the data to make our
own interpretation of what we see in the
results
so um those are some examples uh beyond
that we will take a look at some of the
other applications of microbiome
sequencing and microbiome studies that
are linked to precision medicine
and as you can already imagine from what
we covered so far because of the factors
that we've observed with obesity with
the type of diet with the
exercise levels antibiotics use etc
there's obviously a lot of
a lot of those things could be
influenced during the life of a person
and so as a result the conditions that
we
will see um
you know for example related to disease
are also affected by some of these
things so these could include dietary
interventions prebiotics probiotics and
even
transplantation of the microbiome
to see its effect on specific treatments
or development of specific conditions so
we will take a look at a number of
studies including studies that have led
to
uh translational research results uh for
example here
we can see china approves alzheimer's
treatment that targets the microbiome
right so we will take a look at some of
those potential interventions that are
being explored now
for different types of diseases and in
general as a component of precision
medicine right so not only how do we
focus on a specific type of a treatment
that could influence the microbiome
composition or microbiome functionality
but how can we also incorporate
microbial community understanding into a
an approach for precision medicine
how can this be used for cancer
therapies or therapies in general
including kind of prebiotics before the
treatment or during the treatment or
after the treatment right so we will
take a look at some of those studies as
well
so to summarize the program
will cover in
several different sessions
an introduction to different types of
sequencing techniques
different data repositories we will take
a look at some curated examples that we
have selected to illustrate some of the
approaches for gut skin
microbiome studies
that allow us to understand differences
between healthy
variation in healthy uh represent
representatives of microbiome like the
human microbiome project or associated
with disease and we will also take a
look at ways you can find your own data
sets on repositories like ncbi
that can help you ask questions about
different types of diseases someone
mentioned cancer i mentioned alzheimer's
disease
obviously there's a lot of
types of diseases associated with the
gut uh and we will also take a look at
other like um
other applications that you can easily
find on ncbi
now the goal of this program is really
to prepare you to be able to
independently go from identifying a data
set and then using metagenomics to
answer a research question and uh one of
the ways that you can get started and
this is relevant for anyone whether you
will be joining this training program or
not
we have a free
uh resource on the learn portal that you
already got introduced to in the
beginning of today's session where you
can take an introduction to metagenomics
so let me briefly uh point you to that
free course if you already created an
account you will be able to complete
this whole
byte7 molecules uh course for free and
one of the lessons in this course is an
introduction to metagenomics
so again
let's go to
the learn portal and i will show you how
to find that
so if you are here on the learn portal
you'll be able to go to the courses tab
and right here there's a search bar so
you can simply search here for bytes
and molecules so this is course two
bytes and molecules
and i will post the link to this course
in our chat as well
okay so here once you scroll down you
will see introduction to mega genomics
and some of the material that we covered
in today's session is going to be
available there as well with some links
so if you are not familiar with some of
the terminology that we used in today's
session if some of these things sound
interesting but you don't feel confident
that you will be able to go through all
of the practical sessions we highly
recommend that you go through some of
this material before you start that will
give you a sense of how the material is
organized and what you will be able to
get out of it obviously this is a very
introductory type of
lesson but it will give you a good sense
of what we will do now also inside of
this introductory course you will see
some of the other things that we will
talk about so it's useful to at least
take a look at all of the things that
are present
including those of you that will be
interested in
uh doing more with your data uh we will
be using the t-bone for platform which i
will demonstrate in just a second but
also we will be focusing on some data
visualization and annotation techniques
using r
so if you're not familiar with r at all
you don't know anything about coding we
highly recommend this introduction to
bioinformatics languages uh lesson where
you will be able to learn about the
syntax
uh install and
kind of make sure that everything works
on your own system and then also be able
to try running the code first in the
browser and then copy that code to your
uh
you know once you're done you will be
able to um open that
in your own environment on your own
system like in our studio and try to run
it here so i'll just
uh give you here an example it's not
only good to kind of be able to run the
code but also to understand the code and
you will be able to uh you know check
these different things
that are made here
okay so i will pause here
and i wanted to ask um if there are any
questions that i can answer right now
we're not going to allow uh you know
audio questions at the moment but if you
want to put those questions in the chat
i will go through them one by one
okay how to access free classes
and can we provide you with further
webinars
um yes so after you complete this
particular course
so again this webinar is an
informational webinar we kind of talk
about some of the things related to the
topic and we will introduce other
webinars in the future we actually have
a student uh organized club called the
psionics club which will include free
sessions with uh guest speakers
and
you know you're welcome to join those
but if you want a certificate you all
you need to do is you need to create a
free account on this
portal and then go through the bytes to
molecules course
here under your profile
once you complete that course again here
you will see for example these are some
of the courses that i'm working on
and once you complete a course you will
be able to get a certificate so in fact
if you go here to the certificates tab
you will find here all of the
certificates that are related to the
coursework that you completed
as well as to
um the specific programs if you are
interested to join
okay so i see another question
which part of 16s is best for sequencing
for pair and which length is the best so
these are great questions so again we'll
go into the details uh but just for um
everyone else that is here and would
like to know a little bit more about 16s
sequencing itself
um i will just show a slide uh just one
moment
okay so
uh typically
um
you can see right here for 16s amplicon
metagenomic sequencing this is the full
16s ribosomal rna gene
now this gene is conserved
across
bacteria because the ribosome obviously
has an important function for all
bacteria
but
there are
hyper variable and more conserved
regions so these regions right here are
more or less conserved and then here you
have variable regions so typically 16s
amplicon sequencing combines v v3 and v4
hyper variable regions
these regions together fit nicely
into the typical length of the 16s
or of the systems like miseq so
my seek is useful
um because
uh the sequencing length uh of uh those
matches you know about 300
nucleotides long so it matches the
sequence of those hyper variable regions
um
okay another question um
are you um okay is there an option for a
research publication so this program
that we're discussing today is a
training program so this will introduce
you to some of the skills that you need
to know uh make you familiar with some
of the data sets that you can use for
your own analysis if you end up
developing an analysis we highly
recommend that you go for the advanced
level
the advanced level is designed to allow
you to have a little bit more time and
more interaction with our mentors so
that you can start an independent
project so just to kind of explain what
this independent project is uh right
here if you click under your uh profile
to projects
you will be able to start a project
after you complete the training so after
you reach 10 000 points
and you're ready your profile is ready
you've reached 10 000 points you will be
able to start a project these are the
projects that others have completed in
some of the training programs now a lot
of times these projects take quite a
number of months to complete and that's
why we offer a special program called
the research fellowship that you can
apply for and if you're accepted then
you can work on a research project with
one of our mentors
with support and resources that you
would need to be able to complete that
project on time
so also in the chat you will see that
subranjit barua
who is
in charge of our scientific
communication
is posting information about the
psionics club
uh they there are two exciting free
webinars coming up on metagenomics on
january 8th
with gareth trouble
who will be talking about unraveling the
hidden potential of active microbial and
viral communities
and also on january 21st with dr
christopher taylor
who will speak about metagenomics and
microbial communities in general so
everybody's invited to join uh
the details are in the chat and how you
can join is in the chat as well so if
you're interested to kind of learn more
about the applications of metagenomics
and microbiome
studies uh you're welcome to join those
and uh if you need any more information
please make sure to reach out to uh
subject baruah
subrajeet maybe you can post your email
and address there so if people have any
questions they can reach out to you
okay so thank you again
for
letting me introduce the subject today i
will now pass it back on to sonalika to
speak about registration
thank you so much elia
okay so
this is the pre-registration page where
you all have registered yourself for the
program metagenomics and you will be
able to find all the details of the
syllabus and also the outcomes of each
and every session the topics and the
outcomes and associated resources as
well on this page itself
and while you scroll uh down on the page
itself you will find four live sessions
that we have planned for the session and
these four live sessions will be on
overview of methods and applications for
metagenomics sequencing and analysis big
data analysis platform meta genomics
analysis on the t by info server so here
we'll be uh training and also get some
good hands-on practice with the
pipelines on the server and to mention
the participants of the metagenomics
program will be getting the educational
license where they can run their
pipelines on the server and analyze the
data as well
the third live session will be on
interpretation and meaning that is
statistical analysis visualization and
interpretation using r and the fourth
one will be a very interesting one which
includes the future directions for full
metagenomic sequencing meta
transcriptomics and functional analysis
and we'll be having two guest speaker
sessions as well
where on january 8th that is actually
before the program begins dr gareth
trouble will be talking about unraveling
the hidden potential of active microbial
and viral communities
and the second guest
speaker session will be by dr
christopher m taylor and we have dr
chris here with us so uh
we welcome you dr chris and the session
will be on metagenomics and microbial
communities and this session will be on
21st of january at 3 pm cst
so here is the whole schedule of the
program and also now let's talk about
the registration
so to register yourself for the program
so here we received your
pre-registration as your interest to
invite you for the free webinar so many
of you get confused with both of the
registrations type now to enroll
yourself for the program you need to
visit the program page on the
learn.oxlogic portal and you will be
able to find the link here in the chat
box
okay so once you are here on the program
page again you will be able to first of
all see the whole session schedule along
with the dates the topics to be covered
and the associated resources and these
all resources are linked so this is for
the uh program participants that once
the session has been completed you will
be able to
find i think the the session dates are
to be updated okay so once the session
has been completed you will be able to
look at the session video under each of
the sessions that is after each session
is completed the recording of the same
session will be uploaded under the
sessions tab and also you can watch and
go through the recording and complete
the resources here on the program page
itself
now to enroll yourself for the program
you need to scroll down where you will
get three levels the first one is the
beginner level the second is the
intermediate level and the third one is
the advanced level now what is the
difference between these three different
levels so in the beginner level you all
will be able to be a part of the uh
group sessions that we are going to
conduct and the intermediate level those
who require some extra training or have
some extra questions to ask or need more
precise help from the mentors then they
can go ahead with intermediate training
where they'll get one-on-one mentor
support and in the advanced license the
program participants will be able to
work on a research project and for that
research project they're going to get
some extra time period along with the
usual one and a half month time period
of the program so that is the difference
between these three different level
types now you can enroll or like pick
any of the subscription levels that
answers your requirements the best
and also when you scroll down you'll be
able to find a list of the program um
coursework that that is associated with
this particular program
and the certificate that you will be
getting on the completion of this
particular program
so that was the simplest way how you can
enroll yourself for this particular
metagenomics uh program now if you have
any queries please let me know in the
chat box so that we can
answer your questions
okay so if there are no more questions i
would like to put in oh we have a
question
yes thank you spark so you can reach out
to us at marketing
agricommonslogic.com for any of the
queries and we'll be able to help you
out with your questions and
assist you with your enrollment for the
program so the first session of the
program is on january 10th and uh you
and though the and the first session is
a free session everyone can be a part of
the session and go through the
introductory topics at first and get
insights of what all would be covered
and how the program would be working so
that was all for today's session i would
like to thank you all for being a part
of the session and if your questions
were unanswered or if you have any other
question that might uh
struck after this particular webinar
please feel free to mail us
uh yes definitely alex there are career
opportunities now all these training
programs that are that are being
conducted they are designed in this way
so as alia also mentioned we focus on
project-based learning so yes there are
definitely uh opportunities that you
will get uh
like you will be able to
get yourself a lot of for these
opportunities after completing these
sorts of trainings that omixlogic
conducts
which will help you sharpen the topics
definitely and also help you
give a clear picture of how the concept
of methodologies could be applied to
solve a real life research problem and
do the analysis
yes
we will uh for that for your questions
will be reaching out to you and she'll
let you know uh like what the research
fellowship program is and how it works
and how you can proceed from a research
fellow to an intern with omixlogic and
uh please put your mail id in the chat
box so that first can reach out to you
or you can directly reach out to
marketing and there at logic.com
yes sophia uh
we have few scholarships for the program
as well so we will be able to share with
you all the scholarship form so just
after this particular webinar i am going
to share the recording of the webinar
and along with the recording i'll also
share the scholarship forms that you all
that
the participants can fill out now in the
scholarship form you are required to
submit your curriculum video and after
reviewing your application we will let
you know what scholarship we can provide
you for this particular program now to
make sure that you receive the mails
from our end please make sure that you
add marketing at omixlogic.com
to your mail address book because we
have been interacting with a lot of
users sometimes the mail gets into spam
or maybe promotional box so to get the
mails in your inbox don't forget to add
the marketing and the marketing average
honest logic mail address to your
address book
any other question
okay thank you satya for sharing with me
your mail address i'll be able to share
this with sparshthar and she'll be
reaching out to you with your question
on a research fellowship program and how
you can proceed further with the
internship
opportunity okay thank you everyone for
joining and being a part of this webinar
we'll now meet you all on january 10th
and get started with omixlogic
metagenomics thank you
thank you
you